Over nearly ten years of making
weekly videos for this channel,
I've made some mistakes.
When they're significant,
I will pin a comment to the video,
I'll add a card,
and I'll make a note on the
corrections page on my web site.
But not many people will see those
compared to the original video.
So with only a few weeks left until I
stop posting regular Monday videos,
I figure it's time to
officially look back
at all the things I got wrong
in the last ten years.
And all these mistakes
are sponsored by NordVPN!
Which I have no regrets about using
and whose Black Friday sale is now on.
So: what counts as a significant
mistake for this video? Well,
it has to affect the truth
of what I said.
An editing glitch,
or a typo in a caption,
or a mispronunciation:
they don't count.
They're still going to haunt me
for the rest of my days,
but they happen.
And it has to be a regular Monday video
that's live on this channel:
if it's a mistake in another show,
it doesn't count.
I am sure some of the facts
on Lateral, the podcast I run,
will turn out to
be wrong in future,
despite the question writers'
best efforts, but here,
we're dealing with this series
and this channel.
You should go and listen
to Lateral after, though.
I hated writing this new script,
by the way.
I despise anything I've
made in the past,
this was not pleasant
to look back on,
particularly my early stuff.
But that's where we start.
2014, when my research usually involved
typing a couple of things into Google
to check that I'd remembered
them properly.
"The UK has four Trident-class
nuclear submarines."
Yes, I looked younger ten years ago.
Never mind, it'll happen
to you as well.
And the alternative's worse.
Anyway. Trident is the
nuclear missile:
the submarines are
Vanguard-class.
This is where I
should have learned
to check every little
fact in the video,
not just the big one,
but I still screw
that up sometimes.
I hate that video.
I nearly pulled it entirely.
"...tachycardia, which is
irregular heartbeat."
Nope, tachycardia is
an accelerated heartbeat.
Again, I thought I knew a word,
and so I didn't check it.
Also, hold the phone
further from your face!
"What these have is a
bi-metallic strip."
Modern toasters don't use
bi-metallic strips,
they either use variable resistors
charged by capacitors,
or specialised silicon.
Alec over at Technology Connections
has a great video about them.
Ironically, my video was meant
to correct the internet,
and I got a
big detail in it wrong.
Now, in 2015,
I went to Svalbard,
and I talked about
the 24-hour sundial.
There are several places
I went to early in
"Things You Might Not Know"
and I wish I'd
saved them for later.
And that's definitely
one of those places.
Anyway, I said...
"It is the summer equinox today,
as I record this."
I said summer equinox.
It's the summer solstice.
The equinox is in
spring and autumn,
when the days and nights
are almost equal length.
It's in the name?!
"Equi nox", "equal night"
Yes, I know it's more
technical than that...
I don't care!
Later that year, I was
talking about Concorde.
Again, not a good video, but...
That's a really subtle mistake,
and it's in the timing.
The words are correct,
but I basically moved a
comma in my head,
and then in the subtitles.
The crash was in 2000,
the airlines decommissioned
Concorde in 2003.
I should have said:
"after one of the planes crashed...
"...in 2003 the airlines decided".
Actually, I should have just
rewritten the whole section.
Next video, about tracking nuclear explosions
from Cold War bunkers.
"...ground bursts that
produce local fallout,
"air bursts that spread it
much wider?"
Wrong way round!
Ground bursts from nuclear explosions
spread more fallout than air bursts,
and they spread it wider,
which makes sense,
given they're blowing up
the ground and not the air.
Next up, the St Francis Dam
near Los Angeles.
"More than 50 metres high,
holding back 100,000 tonnes of water."
The St Francis dam actually
held back not 100,000,
but 47 million tons of water.
I mistook the volume
of the physical dam
for the volume of the
reservoir it held back.
In my defence, volume calculations
are really unintuitive.
2016, then.
The year with the most errors.
And we start with a great one:
"In the original version of the video game,
Civilisation, Gandhi was a dick."
Just to be clear, I am talking about
the virtual representation of Gandhi
in a fictional video game!
That story was meant
to be true at the time,
you could find loads of articles
testifying that a bug in
the game Civilisation
meant that the virtual Gandhi's
score for aggression
could go negative and then
loop round to being massive.
But years after I
put that video out:
turns out it was some giant
collective false memory.
That bug does not exist.
I'd never actually played the game.
Now, I also had a whole video
called "Why you should
write down your goals".
Might be the worst video
I've ever done,
and I say "had", because I decided to
move it to being unlisted
after watching it back for this.
It's just a confusing mess,
tacked onto a weird
story about television
and based on one or
two research papers.
And this was before the
replication crisis, too,
when psychology was still flush with
astonishing results
about how people could be subconsciously
influenced and affected by things.
A lot of those studies have not
survived attempts to recreate them.
Thomas Frank made a great video
arguing the counterpoint.
I'm not sure I'd agree
with that either, though?
And I suspect the answer to whether
you should write down your goals is:
eh, I dunno.
Depends on you.
Now, there was the time that me,
and my friends Matt and Paul,
drove along a road that goes through
Russia for about one kilometre,
and as long as you don't stop,
you don't technically enter Russia,
you don't need a visa.
2016, wouldn't do that video now.
But as we're approaching,
Matt says:
"That pole..."
"Yes?"
"Is where they're spying from."
"Ah!" "Oh, you're right!"
Yeah, no, it was just a cell tower.
Or at least, that's what they
want us to think!
there is no evidence for it
being any more than that.
That's my responsibility to check
before putting it in the video.
Matt had just noticed a thing,
and said it,
and because it felt
more like a vlog,
I kept it in.
My fault, not his.
Next one: I was talking about
turbines in thermal power plants.
"hundreds of tonnes of steel,
rotating thousands of times a second"
No, they spin thousands of times
per minute, not per second. Obviously!
If your giant electricity turbine
is spinning several thousand times
a second, something is very wrong,
and probably on fire.
I just said the wrong word.
Probably because I was kinda stressed
from being on top of a wind turbine.
Next up, the first time that I have to
correct a mistake from an interviewee.
I'm not going to play
the actual clip back,
it doesn't feel fair to point out
someone who was kind enough to
give an interview many years ago, but:
I was talking to one of the administrators
of West Virginia University,
about their personal rapid transit system,
the PRT,
and he said the "PRT never shuts down".
Yes it does!
At night. On Sundays. Outside term times.
Regularly when there are mechanical failures.
Like, that shouldn't have made the edit.
I guess it was said aspirationally
or metaphorically,
but another word for that would be...
wrong.
And to be clear,
that's on me.
It's my job to make sure that
the people I interview
don't end up saying
something silly in the final video.
Right. 2017! Things start getting
a little better here,
I start finding my style, we're
three years into making these videos
and I'm actually starting to
fact-check things properly.
Only one error that whole year,
but it's a doozy.
From the zero-gravity drop tower
in Bremen, Germany:
"In the first second after release,
the drop capsule goes 10 metres.
"Next second, 20,
next second, 30,
"Next second, forty...
and then we've used up
"pretty much all the
height there is."
That is wrong. Yes, the speed increases
by 10 metres per second, per second.
I know it's actually 9.8 something,
but, like,
10 metres per second is
close enough for this.
But that doesn't mean it travels
10 metres in the first second,
'cos it's starting at zero
and speeding up.
It'd travel 5 metres in the first second,
then 15, then 25, and so on.
Two separate physicists
fact-checked that script!
Zero gravity is really confusing.
2018, then. One error:
"in the 20th century, more than
200,000 tons of gold
"were extracted from the rock
underneath here."
Giant Mine in Canada produced
200,000 kilos of gold. Not tonnes.
They also produced 200,000 tonnes
of arsenic trioxide dust,
which is the problem
they now have.
You can see how I got
confused with those numbers.
200,000 tonnes of gold would be
roughly the same amount
that the entire world has mined
throughout history,
so, you know,
just slightly out there.
2019. Two weird mistakes in
the same computer-science script.
"If I want to run it on a completely
different type of computer,
"a Mac instead of a PC, I can compile
it for that CPU instead."
Nope, I meant "phone" instead of a PC.
Although given the recent switch
to Apple Silicon,
that's probably now true?
"And we're counting upwards by one
on every sixth clock cycle"
That's every ninth cycle,
it's obvious from the graphics.
And I just said the wrong words
and didn't notice during the edit.
2020. I know that I said typos
in on-screen graphics don't count,
but when you get the
speed of light wrong
because you copied-and-pasted
a 1 into the wrong place,
yeah, it counts.
The other error is
more interesting, though.
I was talking about the rules
on where British programmes
can break for adverts.
"And the host says..."
"Time for a break."
"Like, it's really clear that's not allowed,
there's no other way to read that sentence."
That was true...
back 20+ years ago when the original
version of Millionaire came out.
But in 2008, the rules were changed,
and it's now ambiguous
whether that's allowed.
The old broadcasting code was
still on the regulator's site,
it wasn't flagged as being replaced,
and I just didn't spot that I was using
the old version in my script.
2021. Skipping over the 18th-century
firefighters video that I did a
long correction for last year,
we have two blunders:
"Even the big lithium-ion setup in Australia
that's only caught on fire once so far."
Just like that line years earlier
about Trident-class submarines,
I just thought I knew what I was talking
about and I didn't double-check it.
The graphics are wrong,
Hornsdale Power Reserve
didn't catch fire!
It was the newer Victorian Big Battery,
near Geelong.
Complete blunder on my part,
sorry to the Hornsdale team.
Your battery did not catch on fire!
And then a translation mistake:
"Schusswaffen", firearms,
was mistakenly transcribed as
"Schutzwaffen", defensive weapons.
My transcriber and translator
was German...
...but not Swiss German, and that's
a pretty easy mistake to make.
Honestly I'm not sure I got it
the right way round in this video.
2022. No errors that are
still online,
but in this video about
a chainmail box surrounding a house,
I did originally suggest that the
chainmail was all hand-linked.
The sheets were hand-linked, but
those sheets were made by machine.
The correction's still up, but for once
it was a very brief line
that could be easily and cleanly
cropped out using YouTube's editor,
so I just did that.
And then, this year, at least
this year so far!
Jan Antonín Baťa’s birth year
is 1898, not 1989.
You can see exactly
how that happened.
And the recent video from
the British library said that...
"if you want to get a library card here,
there will be a short interview
"about your research and why you can't
just pull the books or material you want
"from your local or university library."
Apparently the formal interview
requirement for a reader pass,
which I had to go through
a few years ago,
has now been dropped.
There will no doubt be more mistakes.
There's probably one in this video,
because that would be ironic,
and it's probably going to happen.
And when that happens, please:
remember Hanlon's Razor,
which says, in short:
"cock-up before conspiracy",
you should never attribute to malice
what can be adequately explained by stupidity.
As for what has been useful for my research?
Well, NordVPN’s Black Friday deal is on!
I really do use them
a lot while I'm travelling,
because being able to tap
NordVPN’s magic button
and pretend that my computer and phone
are in any one of around
60 countries is really useful.
There are websites that block visitors
from certain countries,
which is unhelpful!
There may be other content you want to
access through geo-restrictions too,
just check the terms of service first.
And I save money on car rental,
because sometimes I can get
a cheaper quote if
my computer appears
to be back in the UK.
NordVPN works on
six devices simultaneously,
across Mac, Windows, Linux,
Android, and iOS,
and there's a
30-day money-back guarantee.
So if you're not sure it's for you,
try it anyway.
I'm happy to keep endorsing them
because I really do use them.
And don't worry if you're
watching this later:
whenever you go to
nordvpn.com/tomscott,
by clicking the link in the description
or scanning the QR code,
you'll still get the best deal
they're currently offering.
But if you're on the fence?
Now's the time to try.